the problem I want to solve is helping
people overcome self-doubt because I
believe self-doubt is the killer of all
of our dreams when we doubt ourselves we
can have all the talent we can have all
the people encouraging us around us but
if we don't believe it's going to be
hard to accomplish what we want well I
want to rid the world of self-doubt
Lewis house I'll come to the show my man
thanks for having me my pleasure you're
even better looking in person even
though you look good on screen too
jacked on screen you know thank you well
for the people that are just listening
we did actually decide that we're going
to dress the same twinsies yeah it's
cute uh thank you for coming to Austin
to see me thanks brother thanks for
having me man
what do you think most people
misunderstand about greatness
most people go for success and they
realize that it's not
the thing that's going to bring them the
most fulfillment success is a selfish
game something I played for 30 years and
there's nothing wrong with the success I
think success is fine but when we just
Chase success by itself it's really
about me look at me winning succeeding
accomplishing making money getting the
awards this is a this is a Me game
and I played that game for a long time
and it worked I got results I got things
money opportunities success
but it didn't solve the uh
the Heart game it didn't solve the game
of how do I feel about me chasing the
success and winning or earning
never felt enough still so I was doing
it from a wound
and I think people
again there's nothing wrong with it but
I just think that greatness is different
than success in the terms that greatness
is a Wii game success is a me game and
greatness includes going after what you
want
but really making an impact on the
people around you and empowering and
lifting others up and helping them
succeed and win too when it's just me
versus the world
I just think that's a lonely game
I would agree there's a a quote from a
mutual friend Alex homozy that got me
thinking quite a while ago about the
tension between success and the desire
to feel like enough so I'm gonna give
you read this out to you success is a
strange thing presumably we want success
because we think a more successful life
will bring us more happiness meaning and
fulfillment here's the problem we
sacrifice the thing we want happiness
for the thing which is supposed to get
it success
failure can make you miserable but I'm
not sure that success will make you
happy one of the most common Dynamics I
see amongst high performance is this
parents want their child to do well
parents encourage their child to do well
by praising when they succeed in
criticizing when they fail the child
learns that praise and admiration is
contingent on succeeding that lesson
metastasizes through early adulthood
into I am only worthy of love acceptance
and belonging if I succeed now powered
by internal feelings of insufficiency
this person is driven to achieve many
things they're prepared to outwork out
hustle and out suffer everyone else
because they're not just running toward
a life they want they're running away
from a life that they fear success and
progress ameliorates the feelings of
insufficiency therefore success and
progress have become prioritized above
everything else yeah and it's
interesting because
um Sarah Blakely who just sold her
company Spanx for I think 1.2 billion
um when I asked her about dealing with
failure and how to overcome this fear of
failure she said that when she was
growing up her dad would have the family
have dinner every night together and he
would ask the same question every night
at dinner what did you fail at today and
he would actually celebrate the failures
and he would encourage them and they
would actually get in trouble if they
didn't have something to share about
what they failed at that day and she
said that that framing around
failure not being a bad thing but
actually a thing that helps you get
feedback on how to get better was the
thing that was celebrated you tried
something that's an awesome thing that
you did this today not only praising
when you succeed but also praising that
you tried you can put effort in you had
a good attitude you failed at something
man you had courage you weren't trying
to look perfect and
keeping the failure up only means you're
going to succeed you play sports growing
up right
you and I know that the only way to
succeed was through failure you know
Michael Jordan missed 50 of his shots
the best baseball players in the world
failed 70 of the time and they were the
best
they missed 70 of the time
and
we celebrate them for their successes
but they also failed a ton ton more than
they succeeded
and I think in athletics we were taught
that you know failure is just feedback
it's a part of the process on how you
succeed I saw this this meme
I don't know a few years ago online
about a meme of like a baby kind of like
wobbling and falling over
and the meme said
a child when learning to walk Falls a
thousand times
and never thinks to himself maybe this
walking thing isn't for me
he just keeps getting up and trying
again until he figures out how to walk
and I think if we can take that approach
on everything like okay I'm just gonna
fall a thousand times but eventually I'm
gonna walk
and I'm not gonna think this isn't for
me but a lot of times we we stop after
one fail today you know we stop after
one try and it didn't work out because
we got judged or criticized by someone
yes certainly a healthy relationship
with failure I think and reframing that
one of the problems that you have in the
modern world is this asymmetry between
what we see of everybody else and what
we see of ourselves right and you don't
really get to see the you get to see the
grand failures of people you know the
bankruptcies and the house going up in
flame and the very public marriage yeah
you see all of the divorces you see all
of that what you don't see the ones that
I think are actually a little bit more
ruthless because it's Death By A
Thousand Cuts the way that they made a
promise with themselves that they
weren't going to hit snooze this week
and yet they did on a morning or the
fact that there was a cookie left out
from last night and they decided to have
it for [__] breakfast like why'd you
have it for breakfast oh well it was
there and I'm sorry but you're saying it
to yourself right and those very mundane
failures I think are
um it's hard to find the balance and I
think this is something that I really
want to dig into with you today this
balance between
um feeling like we're enough and staying
hungry and that's something I want to
get into but first tell me the story
about Jason Redman
have you interviewed a man no oh he's
amazing man it's inspiring
um he was uh
yeah he's he's an inspiring guy who was
at War and
um he essentially got in crossfire he
was supposed to come home
like a week or two later but was
deployed and and had uh he was supposed
to come from home for Halloween I think
in a couple of weeks and he was going to
be done with the deployment
but he had one final mission and he got
in this Crossfire where
he essentially got shot in the face got
shot in the body got shot everywhere and
uh lights out woke up unconscious trying
to figure out where he was
eventually got evacuated from the
location he was in
and he was in a hospital and it was kind
of in and out of Consciousness and as he
woke up and heard one time there were
some doctors or nurses or people talking
in the room talking about how oh man
this is this doesn't look good this is
not gonna end well and this guy's face
is blown off he's got no nose he's got
side of his head blown off you know his
body is really damaged shot in the side
multiple times all these things
and even like in a moment of
Consciousness he heard this and when he
finally was able to communicate he was
just like
this type of language cannot enter my
room this type of communication cannot
enter me otherwise I would not get
better
and he ended up writing this declaration
uh this sign that he put on the outside
of the room that said something like
whoever enters this room you must enter
with joy peace positivity love and
service
any type of negative attitude does not
work for me
so you only enter this room if you
believe in positivity joy and a full
recovery and I will recover to the my
best of my ability and then 20 farther
beyond that because I'm so mentally
tough but if anyone brings negativity in
here
it's going to only hurt me so please do
not enter
I'm paraphrasing the actual quote but
that was the synopsis of it and um he
had this amazing recovery and I think
it's the more the the attitude and the
mindset once something tragic happens to
us really determines how the rest of our
life goes a lot of us have experienced
trauma pain whether it be a huge trauma
or just death by a million Cuts micro
traumas
but it's how we interpret it and the
meaning we give those those events that
really dictate how much peace and
Harmony we have after those things so
he's just an amazing example of and
again he's still on a healing Journey
but his attitude his energy his effort
towards recovery and healing and taking
care of his mind is what's really
inspiring that is the single sort of
unifying criteria between most of the
people I find that's successful that you
know
they all seem to be able to deal with
setbacks yes with difficulties with
challenges it's Man's Search for meaning
it's Victor Frankl or which is probably
the best example of this the if you
haven't read the book yet I recommend
everyone checking it out I mean how
could a man who goes through so much
extreme
trauma around him with thousands of
people dying around him in a
concentration camp live a happy life
after he gets out how is that even
possible
and he was able to create new meaning
from the memory from the wounds from the
traumas
and whatever
we go through if we hold on to any type
of pain around that wound then every
time we feel abandoned taken taken
advantage of or triggered we are going
to react
and I'm not saying it's not justified
it could be justified but is it useful
is reacting with anger and negativity
stress overwhelm is it useful towards
living a beautiful life like Alex
hermosi talked about is it useful
towards Happiness joy abundance is it
useful towards having more energy
towards the mission we're on
and again I'm not saying it's easy but
it's not useful to hold on to that
meaning in a negative way so the
primary takeaway is a man who has a
strong enough white can bear any how
right from man such for meaning how do
people find their why or their mission
it took me a while to figure it out but
I think there's a there's an exercise
you can play with to start trying
for me it's it's first facing yourself
and realizing that there are stuff that
you might need to heal
there might be some wounds that you need
to heal and being on that Journey we
could talk about that later but once
you're on that journey and you're trying
to figure out what is this mission for
this season of life
it doesn't need to be I need to change
the world or cure cancer or something
crazy but figure out where you're at
right now when I was
23 24 I was on my sister's couch for
about a year and a half and that season
of life I couldn't think Beyond just
trying to find how to make enough money
to get my own apartment I couldn't think
beyond that I wasn't like I want to go
change the world I want to go do
something crazy I was like I just need
to survive and get my own life together
so I had a season of life where that was
my mission but I was clear I need to
figure out how to make enough money to
get an apartment and get on my own
then once I accomplished that mission I
could think beyond that I could explore
what is it that I want right now
and when we're in that exploratory phase
of not of trying to get clear on our
mission
think about the three PS the first one
is your passion and this may sound kind
of lame or whatever but I really feel
like when you're interested and curious
about something you're more willing to
deal with the stress and the adversity
that comes your way than if you're not
interested or curious so figure out what
you're really passionate about and ask
yourself those questions about curiosity
lean into that the second p is
um
the the power that you already have
now when I was on my sister's couch I
didn't think I had any talents I didn't
think I had any power I was just got
finished playing Arena Football which
wasn't even good enough to play the NFL
so I was making 250 bucks a week
I didn't have a college degree yet I was
one of the lowest in my in every grade
in school so I didn't think I had Talent
but you really got to assess like what
are the invisible talents that you might
have
an invisible Talent was I was really
good at connecting with people
one-on-one I was really good at seeing
things organizing ideas setting goals
and accomplishing them but I didn't
think that I could make money from it
but I just assessed my talents with my
power
in the second part of the the power is
figuring out what makes you feel the
most powerless
in my early 20s I had a lot of false
confidence you know I was athletic or
whatever and thought I knew a lot but
really I knew nothing
and I acted as if I was confident but I
was really an insecure scared little boy
inside
and so I went through a period of
assessing all my fears I created a fear
list and it was a long list
but one by one I started going all in on
these fears
and making them a superpower making the
thing that made me feel the most
powerless the least amount of confidence
in myself I started overcoming them one
by one public speaking was a big one
learning how to salsa dance was a big
one learning an instrument all these
different things that would create
emotional humiliation right social
humiliation for me was a big fear
judgment was my biggest fear
and so by going all in on those things
and actually overcoming them they gave
me a new skill a new power and actually
more confidence because then I overcame
the thing that I was the most afraid of
and so whatever it is in your life right
now create a list of your fears and
start making those your talents not
insecurities anymore so that's the
second p is the power the third one I
really believe this is when you step
more From Success into greatness
is when you find a problem that you want
to solve the third P so if you're in a
discovery phase of like what is my
mission what is Meaningful to me
what is the thing you want to solve in
the world or for this season of life
and
when we do that we feel more in service
we we feel more useful when we're
solving a problem
if it's a problem we don't care about
and we're we have a curiosity and a
power around something but we do it
towards a problem we don't care about it
just becomes less meaningful it doesn't
mean we can't be successful or make
money out of business but if I was going
to go solve a problem of I don't know
um nail polish remover and go start a
company it just I'm sure I could do it
but it's not useful and it's not a
problem for me right so it's figuring
out what is the thing for me the problem
I want to solve is helping people
overcome self-doubt because I believe
self-doubt is the killer of all of our
dreams when we doubt ourselves we can
have all the talent we can have all the
people encouraging us around us but if
we don't believe it's going to be hard
to accomplish what we want so I want to
rid the world of self-doubt help people
have a new relationship and manage it
because I think that is going to give
them the courage to act on what they do
what they want to do and I know you've
heard a lot of people come to you and
say uh you know Chris I've had an idea
for launching a podcast for five years
years or for writing a book for 10 years
I've had this idea to launch a company
for so long but they don't have the
courage to act it's because they doubt
and at the center of these three fears
the fear of failure success and judgment
is this doubt that I am not enough and
when we can get to the root of that we
can start to figure out how to overcome
it how to heal it and again solving the
problem
finding these three p's the passion the
power and the problem you want to solve
will give you a sense of like okay
here's a Direction I want to start going
towards
and some people might say well I don't
know what problem to solve a buddy of
mine Rory Vaden says that we are
perfectly positioned to help the person
we once were
so if you had lost 50 pounds and you
overcame this problem or if you got out
of debt or have you figured out how to
do relationships but struggled for a
long time you're perfectly positioned to
help that person that you once were in
the world so start evaluating with these
three p's in order to find your
meaningful mission one of the easiest
things that you can do if you want to uh
alchemize suffering into something
useful if you want to transcend it is to
take the things that you've been through
the challenges that you've been through
and then teach other people how to avoid
the pitfalls or expedite the successes
yeah avoid the pain or or get to the
result faster yes precisely and it's
because
you get to Point at whatever caused the
problem to you you know the childhood
bullying or the bad relationship with
your parents or the Heartbreak at the
age of 18 or the financial misery that
you were through whatever whatever the
problem was that you occurred right
and you get to Point at it
retrospectively yeah and say what it
yourself yeah not only did you not get
me but you're not going to get anybody
else out and I'm going to help and
that's one of the it's a really easy
thing or a strange thing actually to do
because
being in service is something that we're
told a lot of the time is transcendent
it makes everybody feel better it's
something that you know the absolute top
self-actualization of Maslow's hierarchy
of needs but then the one above that
would then be service it would be okay
not only if you actualize but then you
open back out into the world and you
think well that sounds great but like
where do I start like do you want me to
go to a soup kitchen what am I supposed
to do and I do think that looking at the
pains that you've been through
in your life
as an identifier of if you went through
it there's probably a lot of other
people that will as well yes you are by
definition of having lived it an expert
in this particular field especially if
you've done some introspection and a
little bit of self-work around it use
that opportunity to help people that
have been through or are going through
what you went through to avoid the pain
in future in their life exactly there's
a good example I talk about in the book
with Robert Green I don't know if you
had him on yet he's amazing
he talked about he was my first
interview 10 years ago and I've had him
on many times but he's he's been
inspiring for a long time
and when I asked him like how did you
find your mission he was like you know I
tried a bunch of stuff I tried a bunch
of stuff that I thought I was curious in
that I thought would be it until I
realized it wasn't so you might need to
try a bunch of things and you might need
to do it to a one-to-one level you know
maybe you're helping a friend overcome
their weight loss journey and you got a
lot of satisfaction from it and you saw
results and you're like all right let me
go take this to three to five friends
but when he was telling me about his
journey he said that
he knew he was passionate about writing
he loved to write he was curious about
it so he wasn't there
he was also like a town of his he got
like good results and he got like some
success from it in school so he's like
all right we go be a writer and he
started I think it was at like a
newspaper or something like that a Small
Town Newspaper he did that for a couple
years but he was like
it's not really really like loving so
let me try like
writing for TV shows so he goes into
Hollywood tries TV shows he's like I
actually don't like writing in these
writing rooms like my personality
doesn't jam with like 10 people in a
writing room or whatever it didn't work
for him let me try movie scripts
tried movies and he's like I just don't
like this industry then he tried writing
novels and he was like writing these
books but they weren't really getting
traction
and this was like 10 15 years of him
trying a bunch of different stuff
until he said you know what I've got
this idea like I want to solve this
problem
and I want to write about a book in a
unique way that I've never seen written
before and I want to create this thing
that I just don't feel like it's out
there but I feel like it needs to be and
he tried to pitch it and no Publishers
were really interested in this
uh but he finally got some traction got
it off the ground and then
48 Laws of Power you know became this
massive hit and I believe that was his
first kind of main book that he wrote in
his series
and it was written differently it looked
different than all these other books out
there but it was solving a problem for
him that he wanted for himself and he
wanted to help others with
and then he's like you know what I just
figured out that I was going to write
these unique type of books in a unique
way and solve this problem use my
passion my power and solve this problem
it took him 10 15 years to get there
probably more and it keeps evolving but
trying a lot of things around his
interests is what got him there and this
is one of the best non-fiction authors
of our era exactly yeah you [__] about
and failed and sort of circled the edge
of the exactly the rim for a very long
time yeah and maybe you got to try a
bunch of stuff in your interest to see
like what's going to work for you one of
my friends William Costello says
research is research absolutely he's an
academic he actually researches in sales
so I'm not going to comment on whether
or not that's that's true for him
um okay so you've mentioned those three
big fears that are kind of wrapped
around your self-doubt conversation here
for failure success and judgment
how can someone do a post-mortem on
their self-doubt how can they analyze
where their negative self-talk and lack
of self-belief is coming from
man one of the hardest things I've ever
done is just look myself in the mirror
and say do I recognize who I am and ask
myself who am I and really take a look
and say what are the things that are
holding me back emotionally and
psychologically what are the biggest
fears and doubts that I have it was hard
to face this 10 years ago and I faced it
many times since then how old do you
know I'm gonna be 40 in two three weeks
yeah
so I kind of started this journey right
around 29 of the school of greatness and
just kind of overcoming myself
from not feeling happy getting success
but not feeling fulfilled
and it's been a journey of
allowing myself to be a beginner
constantly and saying okay I'm gonna get
feedback from as many different types of
experts therapists healing individuals
as possible to see what I can do to
break through from the self that does
not serve my highest self
so it's been a 10-year journey of
healing and recognizing and when I think
I figured it out I'm humbled and my ego
is shattered over and over again so now
I just try to stay as humble as possible
and say I I don't know anything and I'm
always a beginner I have wisdom but
there's always a lot more to learn just
like I think you do really well with
your show I think it's a beautiful thing
but again going back to creating a list
of all my insecurities was a big thing
that helped me because that was the
place where I was most reactive I 10
years ago I had a belief an identity
that was unhealthy that I was based on
results and how I would respond and
react I was angry I was frustrated I
would get you know depressed at times I
wasn't in a depressive state where I
wanted to commit suicide but I would be
in my room for a week at a time kind of
in a depressed state based on results
what sort of results
based on how I would react in situations
I would react with anger when I was
triggered I would get depressed when
something didn't work out for me and I
would tell myself over and over
internally and externally that I'm
stupid that I'm such an idiot I can't
believe I made that mistake what a dummy
I would say these words so I was my own
worst critic
based on how I showed up
and 10 years ago I created a new
contract with myself I started to have a
lot of breakdowns in my life and I went
to a an emotion intelligence leadership
event that kind of kicked off my journey
of healing and trying different healing
modalities
and in this experience I created a new
contract I was able to see and face
myself and realize the narration I've
been having with myself and to others
about me has not served my happiness
if we recorded the things that we said
to ourselves consistently and played it
on a loudspeaker they probably put us in
a mental institution for most people and
if we said the things that we say to
ourselves to our lovers and our best
friends they probably wouldn't be our
friends
so it was creating a healthy identity
with myself I didn't know what that
meant I thought I worked hard and I was
disciplined I could out train people I
could work hard what all these things
but I couldn't I didn't learn to accept
and love myself
but also not be complacent right how do
you accept and love who you are and want
to continue to grow to be more so I
created a new contract instead of being
angry
depressed
and stupid which was the results I was
creating in my life based on the
narration and the identity I had with
myself
I created a new contract that I
literally wrote down and said aloud and
signed to myself on a piece of paper and
I said I am a loving passionate wise man
this is not a mantra just speak in the
mirror constantly this is a new belief
that I had to step into and become
and I had to create something for myself
that was authentic not a lie
I knew I was a loving guy but I had
anger inside of me so I had to figure
out how to get to the root of letting go
of anger but I knew there was love
inside of me
I knew I was passionate but I had a lot
of kind of depressed energy as well that
I was holding on to so I had to learn
how to get rid of that
I didn't think I was smart I didn't
believe I was smart because I was in the
bottom of my class all through school
dyslexic growing up is very hard to read
and write in general
so saying the word smart would have
actually been a lie to me I can't lie to
myself
but I did think I was wise I was like I
have Street smarts I have wisdom from
from different experiences and I believe
that was wise and so I said I'm a loving
passionate wise man
and I and I had to do a couple of things
it wasn't just shouting this as
affirmation as Goggins says it's not
something you do and just get better I
had to act accordingly every moment of
every day to be those things I had to
create and reaffirm those things through
my actions consistently then I became
them and I believed them more
until
you know letting go of the anger
depression and the feeling stupid left
me it took time to integrate but that
practice of creating a new contract was
huge for me do you think that beliefs or
action comes first
well here's the thing a lot of people
can take action and still not believe
you know I was uh I was in eighth grade
playing basketball and I was watching
The Varsity
uh team play and sometimes I'd practice
with them because I was taller
and there was this athlete who was the
freakiest looking athlete that I've ever
seen in my life had a 45 inch vertical
could dunk at will at any moment just
run into the RAM and just 360 Tomahawk
jamming could score it will was one of
the smoothest basketball players I've
ever seen
he took the action
he put in the Reps he worked hard all
those things happened but he didn't
believe in himself
and it's interesting everyone was like
you're you're like a god out here you
can do anything in practice but when the
games came he didn't believe so he had
the talent he put in the Reps all those
things but he still didn't believe in
himself and here's the thing it doesn't
matter
if
it really doesn't matter if the world
believes in us if we don't learn to
believe in ourselves we may not create
the results we want but on the flip side
what is cool it doesn't matter if the
world's against us if we learn to
overcome it and believe in ourselves we
can do some amazing things so there's a
combination that once you take the
action you still have to learn to
believe and when we have that negative
script constantly running
I think it's hard to overcome ourselves
with that identity it's hard to overcome
the negative script without any evidence
that suggests the otherwise 100 yeah you
can't fake it correct yeah asking for
confidence without competence is
delusion yes but having competence
without confidence is what I call
imposter adaptation wasted Talent well
the the you've got all this talent but
then you don't take action you have to
accept it after a while
if you continue to disprove all of the
concerns and imposter syndrome that you
have internally by succeeding in the
real world
if every single time that you're faced
with a challenge you overcome it and yet
your imposter syndrome still persists
you have to admit to yourself it's got
nothing to do with your competence and
everything to do with your addiction to
feeling like an imposter exactly so I
think that in your inability to think in
a way that serves you you're thinking in
a way and believing a way that
discredits all the hard work you've done
you were being the worst critic when
other people are like you're amazing
you've got this we believe in you
but we have to learn how to overcome our
own negative self-critic and I think
that's a hard thing to do and they
usually don't teach us how to do this in
school or our parents may not teach us
unless they have that skill that's why I
think it was so inspiring that Sarah
blakely's dad was like let me celebrate
you when you fail and tell you that you
are still love you're loved you're
enough I celebrate you yes and great job
you tried something you overcame
something
and I think that's inspiring but when we
uh do all the hard work and we still say
uh no I'm not good enough or I don't
know if I can do it then why are you
working so hard just go be lazy yeah
it's it's a very difficult one man
because we know the the strategies that
got us here wherever here is even if
it's step two right or step two thousand
we know that the strategies that got us
here were probably paying very close
attention to every small element of
whatever practice it is that we're doing
where is scrutinizing our game tape
we're listening back to the podcast
we're looking at the traffic on the
website were getting other people to
read our article whatever it is that we
do right whatever the thing is that you
do you you scrutinize it and you use a
lot of cognitive effort to look at it
and the problem is that that same degree
of scrutiny applied over a long enough
time
doesn't actually end up facilitating
performance past a certain point yeah
and this is why I think that the tools
that got you here won't get you there is
a really interesting way to look at this
stuff yeah look when you start out there
are certain things you need to do the
degree of attention that you need to pay
to the things that you do the level of
resolution that you need to look at
things through is great but if you Now
podcast episode 1500 or whatever that
you're going to release next week was
looking at it through the same lens that
you looked at episode one everything
would be moving so slowly it wouldn't be
as easy or as graceful yeah so I do
think that there is this
balance between belief and action in my
opinion because I was someone that and
still does deal with chronic
unconfidence at times right
very very unconfident especially going
through my 20s oh yeah massively hidden
behind a very Brash album now uh less so
now but the reason for that is because
I've got a stack of undeniable proof
that I am USA exactly to quote almost
evidence yeah but a lot of people have
evidence and they still don't believe
they still don't believe so it would be
that imposter adaptation thing where
it's like there is so much undeniable
evidence yeah that you are that you
literally have to be delusional to
believe the opposite uh or you don't you
haven't been trained on how to believe
in yourself and accept who you are
because a lot of people are striving for
Perfection and it hurts their
performance and we must think how can I
just perform better
and let go of perfection
Perfection I don't think will ever
happen if it does great maybe it happens
for a moment or a few moments but
striving for for performance should be
the factor that everyone focuses on not
Perfection because that's what's getting
in the way of your results yeah I mean
there's a great quote from
um Thiago Forte where he says that uh
publishing publishing things to
Perfection is a low leverage activity
which is why some of the best performers
in the world their work has a
rough-edged half-assed quality to it oh
that's good yeah because the difference
between for most people unless you're in
Elite Sport getting from 95 to 97 is not
actually going to make a massive amount
of difference to your learning in terms
of practice or the way it's issued to
the market or the audience or whatever
but it's going to take you twice as long
so hard maybe even longer yes to get
from 95 to 97. now if you are Usain Bolt
the goal is to get that 100
000 to the percent right that's what
you're playing with yes but for most
people I think just time and mentioning
getting things done
there's not one thing that I've done
that's perfect in the last 10 years of
my show not one thing I could look back
at every episode of man and cringe at
everything that I do constantly and like
I could have done that better or Chris
did this better than me on this thing I
could have done this it could have
looked better or changed this up I could
compare to everyone in the world and be
crippled by that comparison of it's not
perfect yet
but the one thing that has served me was
just being willing to put stuff out
there consistently and improve over time
and I still don't feel Perfect 10 years
later I feel feel like man I got a lot
of room to grow there's a lot of stuff I
can do to get better but it doesn't hold
me back from my performance I still show
up deliver consistent results and
perform as opposed to focus on being
perfect what's the fear conversion
toolkit
for me it's really transforming your
thoughts your behaviors and actions into
congruency and in harmony with moving
forward towards your meaningful Mission
because a lot of fear holds us back from
acting the fear of failure success or
judgment so we don't act because we
don't believe we're going to get the
results or we believe something bad will
happen
and at the the core root of this fear of
failure is
I'm not enough and so what we can
convert that into knowing I am enough
maybe I'm not where I want to be maybe
I'm not as good as I want to be maybe
I've made mistakes maybe I've messed up
maybe I've hurt people maybe people have
hurt me accepting the past and learning
how to accept it and say okay I'm not
happy with where I am but I can learn to
accept who I am
not beating myself up anymore and start
going all in on my fears until these
fears start to disappear when we can
convert it into saying I am enough and
actually realizing it which I think is
one of the hardest things that's why
people lack confidence that's why they
beat themselves up what's why they harm
themselves that's why they go on
antidepressants because they don't feel
enough
so it's really learning the skill of
feeling and believing we are enough
where we are
and also not being complacent and not
giving effort to improving and growing
it's both in accepting where we are and
saying I'm also going to take massive
consistent imperfect action to improve
over time
when I think we have fears that hold us
back and we do nothing to do them
we're always going to feel stuck or
trapped in some area of life so it's
really paying attention to what are my
biggest fears creating a game plan and a
system with support I don't think you
should do it alone in order to go all in
on them until you start to overcome them
when we can do that again it's
converting fear into confidence like you
said you have undeniable evidence and
proof based on putting in the Reps
consistently if you didn't have that
evidence or proof you still might be
lacking confidence or fearful of certain
things because you didn't take the
action and that's what really what it is
a lot of us are unwilling to face the
fear and acknowledge that something's
wrong with us or something is not
perfect or something's off so we mask it
we put on a mask to fit in and belong to
others but what we are saying when we do
that is we do not belong to ourselves
I'm trying to do something for you to
like me because I don't like myself so
I'm putting a mask on I'm projecting a
false sense of confidence performative
and again this is not right or wrong
good or bad I'm not judging people
because I did all these things most of
my life
is it useful is it effective towards
your meaningful mission is it going to
help give you more energy feel more
peace and Harmony When you go to sleep I
don't know about you Chris but I
couldn't sleep for most of my life until
I hit 30. because I would ruminate for
an hour hour and a half almost every
night just staring up at the ceiling
thinking stressing anxious about
myself and not feeling good enough
and I would try to perform and work
really hard to feel better but it still
didn't work well I know what it feels
like to lay awake at night wondering if
you're doing the thing that you're
supposed to be doing I'm wondering why
your life's going and if this is
actually how you're supposed to spend
your days and am I really fulfilling my
potential and why don't I have the
things that I want why don't I feel the
way that I should why is life not I
don't know it felt discordant it felt
like chords that were being played Out
Of Tune with each other
um I do think
one of the easiest ways and this is me
speaking to myself but also anybody that
feels like okay I don't have the
self-belief but I also don't also don't
have any proof for me the easiest place
to start is to do action and the reason
is for the same reason that going to the
gym is easier than meditating that you
can see the Reps that you do right I I
know that I've spent 30 minutes writing
after sitting down for an hour and a
half and procrastinating yeah yeah on on
writing my blog post right on starting
my sub stack on choosing the [__]
logo for my website or whatever it is
that you decide to do that is it is so
obvious to me that that is work that is
done and it is more undeniable yes than
I spent time digging through the trauma
of my past introspectively and changing
my beliefs yes for me and this may be
different for girls I'm not sure but
certainly for guys I think that an
action-focused
I did a thing today I can take it off a
list you know the the artist inside all
of us is going to be satisfied when we
decide that we're going to have ticked
off the the boxes of course here's the
thing it's a bow fan I think it's taking
massive imperfect action
on building confidence and Reps but I
think it's also that can be a cover-up
that can be a mask if not addressing the
wounds that hurt you at some point so
it's we don't have to sit here and think
about our past pains and traumas every
single moment of every day
there's a season and a period of time to
start and develop that healing
integrating process
for me it wasn't until the last couple
years when I really went all in on every
area of my life that caused me the most
pain
and re-imagining it facing it doing
physical exercises with it having a
coach to support me emotionally process
it
to where I felt the most freedom and
peace of my heart that I've ever had in
my life it doesn't mean I don't face
challenges and stresses in my day-to-day
but I sleep peacefully at night and I
am way less reactive about what happens
in life whereas before I used to be in
fight or flight mode whenever I felt
triggered or someone was out to get me
and so I could still take action and
build this unwavering evidence that I
have put in the refs I've got skills now
I've got the confidence
but if I'm still triggered emotionally
by someone cutting me off in the street
it's not right or wrong good or bad it's
just taking energy away from being more
effective
and being driven to to deliver results
using that anger that fuel that pain
worked for 30 years of my life and
getting success but it didn't bring me
fulfillment
so it was unsustainable that drive to
prove people wrong to win at all costs
to get back to the bullies of the people
that made fun of me uh or to just
overcome all the challenges I faced
it didn't give me peace it didn't give
me fulfillment actually when I
accomplished the goals I became angrier
because I thought this is supposed to be
the thing that brings me more joy why am
I not feeling it why do I still not feel
enough
so it's taking the action so you build
the confidence but I think if you have a
story or a memory that still triggers
you today that thing has power you over
you that thing is still consuming and
controlling your mind
and holding you back from what I believe
is your authentic self talk to me about
this balance between feeling like you're
enough and staying hungry there's
certainly a big cohort of people that I
know who
internally have a fear went to the
complacent they don't want to get
complacent dealing with the [__] because
they know that the it won't drop on
their shoulder yeah is part of the fuel
now it's an incredibly toxic fuel but
it's [__] potent yeah I mean you hear
you hear about some of the greatest
athletes of all time you see you know
Tom Brady talking about I've always had
this chip on my shoulder and look at him
he's the greatest athlete
I mean the greatest quarterback of all
time undeniably based on results right
um but who knows if he's really
fulfilled or happy and I don't I don't
want to sit here and judge either way
you've got Michael Juve on the show
right yeah yeah and so he I asked him
this question I said do you think the
most high performers on average are
happier or more miserable than the
normal person he said without his doubt
they're more miserable yeah I think so I
think so unless you find some other way
to create Harmony in your life think
about this way think about how much of
an outlier you have to be to be an
unbelievable High performer and then
within that cohort of the best in the
world there's outliers within that that
are the ones that have somehow managed
to be balanced with it
yeah
I just think here's I've had some
conversations with some mutual friend of
ours about this I don't want to let this
chip off my shoulder because then it's
not going to drive me anymore yep and
here's the thing I don't feel like I
really don't feel like I have a chip on
my shoulder anymore I did
and I don't feel like I do I feel like
more
I have a desire to fulfill my mission
and I have a desire to
give my best to my Creator you know if
that's God great I'm here for a reason I
don't really know what that is but if it
is a reason I want to make sure I give
it my all and I want to give my all to
the mission of this season of life
and that's more of what I'm afraid of is
not like a chip on my shoulder about
three kids from middle school that
picked on me or someone that picked me
last on a dodgeball team or the the guy
that sexually abused me or all these
things it's not like I'm gonna go show
them
what does that do for me it doesn't do
anything for me it's more how can I be
of service to my mission how can I show
up for my mission and by doing that man
I want to be super proud of myself how
can I show up for my friends my family
my community in a big way man that gives
me energy and fuel knowing I'm making an
impact rather than knowing I'm right
winning or being successful
that gives me this like
renewable energy it gives me like this
fuel that I feel like will never burn
out I wonder whether part of the
selection criteria for the people who
have a
forward running towards something they
want as opposed to running away from
something they fear mentality is to do
with that group that they've got around
them whether they have a support
structure or not because a lot of the
creators and and other discussions that
I see about this online one of the
common threads between the people that
seem to have the more
Lone Ranger I'm gonna use this chip on
my shoulder thing to drive me forward is
that they don't have that support
structure but I'm good Community they
don't have good friends or family or
Community to really support them because
they've kind of pushed everyone away of
just this obsessive nature I feel like
so what do you say to people who don't
have a strong support system or
Community around them at the moment what
what can they do
I just think this is this is not a loan
this is not a one-man game I just think
it's a
it's a game we're supposed to play with
other people you know and I used to be
the kind of the Lone Wolf and and it was
me versus the world as me against the
world with everything and I always
thought the world was against me
and I'm gonna have that feeling of
anxiety stress and overwhelm when it's
me versus the world as opposed to We're
All in This Together you do realize how
narcissistic that is for the people that
have that Viewpoint right you think that
the world is against you the world
doesn't think twice about you the world
that's what it feels like though I mean
where did it yeah I'm aware and I'd see
this online and I had the same I had
this the exact same thing this is me
speaking to my past self like dude the
world doesn't think twice about you
they're thinking about their own stuff
yeah
people you would be way way way way more
self-confident if you realize how rarely
other people gave a [__] about anything
that you did and yet this it is a
incredibly narcissistic victim mentality
that look at what the world is doing to
me look at how hard I have it it's me
against the world I'm gonna Sisyphus my
way up this hill I'll bear the brunt of
all of it you know the weight of the
world yeah precisely this existential
burden it's like bro you have had some
traumas that are absolutely independent
to you and quite rightly you require
sympathy for that but it's not like the
world made this happen yeah yeah you
know
who is uh who are some top athletes in
your mind that you think of when you
think of sports and the greatest
athletes of all time yeah
Brady yep
uh Cristiano Ronaldo yep and
when they got to you know I don't know
if you've had Tim Grover on but he's
I've read about him in my book working
with Jordan and Kobe
um when Jordan and Kobe won their first
championship they didn't get there alone
they had a coach and they had teammates
around them and when they won their
first championship they didn't say to
the coach coach thanks for getting me
here I'm gonna do this on my own next
year they actually went and hired more
Specialists more coaches more support to
help them get to that 95 to 97 right
like you talked about
and to stay on top to overcome the
challenges that come they enlisted more
support but I think a lot of us and I
think that's wisdom finding coaches
finding people to support you and give
you real feedback not criticism but how
to adjust to perform better
and when we try to do it alone I just
think we are exhausting our energy I
have a coach for almost every area of my
life I've got a business coach I've got
a fitness coach nutrition coach I've got
an emotional coach
and I also just have mentors friends
personal advisors that I lean on when I
need support
I don't think it's weak to ask for
support I think it's wise and when we
can lean on mentors like you said or
just watching your show is wise when
people watch you or listen to you you're
their Mentor or you're bringing on
people that are their mentors
and they're learning things on how to
overcome challenges faster they're
minimizing their time to accomplishing
they're dealing with less pain because
of it that's called wisdom that's not
weakness well certainly for the people
who don't have the resources to maybe be
able to get five five coaches for each
area of their life you have the
opportunity to surround yourself with
the greatest Minds that you like with
your content creator you know I this was
me at some 34 now and this was me at
sort of 27 28 you know the Advent of
your Jordan Petersons your Sam Harris is
you're a Lander button from the school
of lives and I was in a working-class
town in the northeast of the UK I'd met
about a million people throughout my
career of running night nightlife stuff
and I'd managed to have a handful of
friends so after knowing a ton of people
precisely I was the guy on the front
door of the nightclub every single
person knew my name every single person
in that City knew my name for a decade
and I had a handful of friends because I
was struggling to connect yes
and
I knew that there was something wrong I
knew that I needed to find insight and
answers and guidance toward a more
effective version of me yes
foreign and yet I was in a world where
those Role Models seem to be quite
scarce so yeah very much so I mean dude
nightlife Believe It or Not nightlife is
not exactly a hotbed for philosophical
and life Direction inside yeah
um
and I'd come from I talked about this
with Goggins the reverse role model a
world where I had people like the sort
of person I didn't want to be like a lot
surrounding you yeah so not that they
were close to me mum and dad were
absolutely fantastic but
you know
the sports that I played when I was
younger especially because in qriket
it's a game where physicality isn't a
big deal skill is which means that you
can immediately at 13 or 14 years old
play adult level so you get exposed to
marriages and and kids and divorces and
breakups and financial worries and
alcohol addiction or or gambling or
money worries all of these things you
get exposed to it's like a crash course
in human life at the age of 14 or 15. so
I started to see people where I thought
well okay I don't want his relationship
with money and I don't want the way that
he shows up for his wife and I don't
want this and this and this so those are
way markers in the ground that taught me
what I didn't want but finding a
community that a role model that you can
admire that you can look up to that
makes you feel like you have a direction
that you're moving in that's effective
yes
is hard man and yet we have the
opportunity now to find people yes on
the internet that are the exact big
brother that you never had exactly
here's here here's how I did it early on
because I knew going from Sports into
life you know after I was done playing
Arena Football got injured on my
sister's couch for a year and a half
I was like I don't know how to get a job
I don't even have a degree this was in
2008 when the uh housing crisis was
crashing in America so the economy was
like very shaky
I was just like I have no clue what I'm
gonna do school did not prepare me for
life
so what am I gonna do let me just think
what I would do as an athlete I need
some coaches I need to find a coach and
go do this life thing
and early on at this time for a year and
a half I was just like man I'm so afraid
of so many things I created this fear
list
and I was a long list and I was just
like
I just don't want to feel like a piece
of [__] anymore I don't want to feel
like crap knowing that I have all these
fears on this list knowing that these
things are consuming my energy and they
hold me back from taking action
so I found my mentors by going all in on
my fears one of the most public speaking
I met someone who was a public speaker
um a professional speaker one around the
country speaking to colleges
and I asked him like man I can't even
get up in front of three people and give
a five minute conversation without
stuttering and stumbling
what can I do
and he gave me the path he said go to
Toastmasters every week for a year it's
going to give you Toastmasters is a
public speaking class
it's going to give you tools and give
you practice and give you feedback in a
community
I don't even know what it was but I said
okay cool I'm going
I he said go to the you know go to a
bunch of different Toastmasters clubs in
this city I was in Columbus Ohio so go
check them out join the one that scares
you the most that's going to push you
the farthest
so I went to five different ones and one
of them I was like oh this one is the
one I do not want to be in because
everyone's a pro everyone's in suits
everyone's like unbelievable I do not
belong I got a backwards cap I got a
cast ons on my arm in this position you
know 90 degrees with a cut off shirt
looking like a bum these are all like 30
40 50 year old Pros actually getting
paid to speak and I go well this is
where I need to be
by going there
I met a guy and one of these kind of
events there was um
kind of like free appetizers and food in
the back it was like a guest event you
can come check out yeah so at the end of
the the event I went back there this is
when I'm on my sister's couch I've got
no money three credit cards debt student
loan debt
a bum arm I can't you know I'm gonna
cast for six months got no job no money
and there is a bunch of it's probably
one of my lowest moments just for me
personally
um is being injured losing my identity
being on my sister's couch and in the
back of this room there's like all the
you know whatever carrots and broccoli
and chips and things like that
I I've got no money for food I'm
stuffing it in my mouth and then I get
all the napkins and i stuff food in my
pockets stuffing all this food this guy
who spoke sees me goes what are you
doing I go uh this is kind of my food
for the day
and he goes let me just buy lunch
there's a diner next door so he he
bought me lunch
he had spoke that day and I watched him
speak
he became a mentor of mine and a coach
in public speaking for that whole year
he helped me write my first book he gave
me the confidence and the courage and
the coaching to then take action I would
not have met him had I not gone after my
biggest fears I did this as well in
salsa dancing salsa dancing was a huge
fear of mine specifically specifically
salsa dancing why not Ballroom
well it's an element of Ballroom right
so salsa dancing is an element of
Ballroom so I here's why
um I couldn't dance growing up right and
being a white dude in the middle of Ohio
you're not known for being like cultured
as a dancer right this just wasn't it
yeah I feel you and I lived in college
above a my brother was uh he's the
number one Jazz violinist in the world
today
he's uh a master and he's played all
around the world with the greats all
these different things
when I was in college
I had an apartment there was a studio
apartment I don't know maybe twice the
size of this room
and it was um
it was above a a jazz club it was like
upstairs above a jazz club so my brother
got me the the apartment because he had
stayed there a couple times or whatever
and he knew the owner and so the every
week there was jazz music downstairs
like being played but one night a week
they had a salsa band and all the
salsados in Ohio would come out to
Columbus Ohio and dance so I would go
down just curious watching Jazz and then
I saw salsa one time and I go I do not
belong here I'm watching this
it's you know I'm the only white guy
there I'm a foot taller than everyone
and they are you know singing in a
language that I don't understand they
are dancing a language that I don't
understand and I feel extremely
vulnerable and uncomfortable but I was
just fascinated watching these
individuals dancing together and
how can they just pick someone randomly
and know how to dance the language of it
I was just like this is fascinating but
I was so intimidated I [__] you not for
three months I would go down there and
sit in the corner kind of creepy but not
that creepy because I wasn't like
staring or gawking or just I was just
like mesmerized at the music and it was
just like beautiful
and I got to know people over these
three months and they always ask me to
come dance these girls and I go no way I
don't want to make you look I don't want
to humiliate myself or make you look bad
because I can't dance like these other
guys
and so that became a huge fear because I
was just like the thing I'm resisting
it has power over me it makes me feel
not confident just watching it let alone
thinking about taking a step on the
dance floor so that was another thing I
met a guy who I thought was the best
dancer and he
was incredible his confidence his Poise
like his Charisma just how he moved and
I was like it would be a dream to be
able to dance like this guy he became my
coach and Mentor for the next year
finally after three months
one girl like yanked me on the Dance
Floor after trying to get me for for
weeks I go out there I am like drenched
in sweat I'm so terrified we go into the
middle of the dance floor it's crowded
it's packed music is playing people are
swinging and dancing all around us
I am just stepping on her feet I'm like
apologizing constantly I'm looking down
the whole time after about five minutes
of just fumbling around like a giant
idiot
she grabs my head and pulls my my chin
up and looks at her she goes Lewis
just look around just have fun look
around
and I'm looking around and everyone's
dancing and smiling and laughing and
having fun and something I realized no
one is looking at me no one cared about
what I was doing and even if they did
maybe they looked at me for a moment and
said oh this guy's not that good but
then they went on to their own lives
they're dancing they're having fun
and it was at that moment I was like oh
wow it was I was so afraid of the
fear of judgment the humiliation that
could happen
and who cares if a few people were
making fun of me or laughing at me I
didn't even see it and
I was hooked I started going out four
times a week for the next six months I
started taking private lessons group
lessons doing everything I could this
guy started coaching and mentoring me
and within six months I literally became
fluent in salsa dancing and then for I
don't know seven eight years I traveled
the world to all these different
countries to the top salsa clubs in the
world and when enter
not knowing anyone and go find the the
top dancer in the club and I would just
watch and see who's the best girl dancer
and I would go up and ask her this was a
a challenge that I gave myself and most
of the time I'd get rejected and I was
like awesome okay let me overcome this
fear let me just get back into this I'd
find other people to dance with and
eventually at the end of the night those
girls that rejected me would ask me to
dance because they would see that I
could dance but they didn't think I
could originally so I did this in so
many different areas writing books
public speaking salsa dancing launching
a business I started to go all in on
these things by taking action the thing
you talked about building reps people
found me I found mentors and coaches in
that process of action of humiliation
and they said hey let me give you a few
pointers let me give you this now I took
the action on what they said
I think one of the worst things you can
do today is try to reach out to someone
and say hey can I pick your brain for
five minutes and then they tell you
exactly what to do and you don't do it
for me it's the worst thing you can do
because a coach or a mentor or an
advisor
wants to know that you took action on
the thing they told you and you got some
type of result
so I just said whatever people tell me
to do I'm going to do it they've got
results I want to learn how to do this
and that's what I did pretty much
everybody is one dm away from a message
that'll probably change their life yeah
exactly but a lot of people just fear to
take action consistently and they don't
want to humiliate themselves or fail and
lose over and over again I was willing
to humiliate myself every day
for years if it was going to give me
Freedom if you still got the skills now
I can dance with the best dancers in the
world in a salsa club setting I'm not a
ballroom dancer
there's a different form and style and
pose but if I I can you can drop me in
any salsa club in the world
and in a moment I can grab someone and I
can do anything I need to do yeah that's
cool but I've done it for 17 years I put
in the Reps and for weeks I would go two
three four times a week four years I
mean I obsessed about it just like
obsessed about learning how to read and
write as an adult
in eighth grade I had a second grade
reading level and I couldn't read or
write even through college and so I had
to learn these things in my 20s in order
to be effective as a writer and write
books if I had a a message I wanted to
get out there
speaking I had to overcome the fear of
speaking same thing with writing same
thing with interviewing all these things
were fears I didn't know how to do any
of these things but I overcame them and
continued to overcome them through
action consistently what's the mindset
in motion cycle
let me get to the page here because it's
a graphic get it up there's some graphic
here for this
um
you find it here
and before I get to that actually I want
to talk about the difference between a
powerless mindset and a greatness
mindset because I think this is this is
going to be interesting this is where I
actually think people should start is is
going over the power of this mindset
versus the greatness mindset then I'll
get back to the this other part here
since this popped up for me so wherever
you're at right now whether you're
crushing it or succeeding
or you feel like you're stuck and you're
in between in between transitions maybe
a career breakup or you're you just sold
a company whatever it is
on page 201 I have this graphic
um and I can just share with you guys to
so you understand it
is to assess and see am I in a powerless
mindset or in a greatness mindset and
there's really six key factors
and this does not mean you are good or
bad right or wrong as a human being it
does not mean you're not lovable or
anything like that it just means
is your mindset as effective as it can
be or is it holding you back that's all
it means
and a powerless mindset is someone who
lacks a meaningful Mission I think your
interview with Jordan Peterson was great
because he talked about you know making
sure you have a direction an aim
something to go towards
a lot of people don't have a clear
direction or the direction
isn't the right direction it's an
inauthentic Direction and so they might
hit it but realize it's not what they
wanted
but either way I believe a man without a
mission is a dangerous man when we have
no clear Direction That's when bad
things usually tend to happen
and you see a lot of our military who
struggle and suffer after their mission
ends and they come home and they don't
know what to do next and thankfully
there's a lot of programs for our men
and women who are who have returned to
get them back on a new Mission but I
just think lacking a meaningful Mission
we are going to power this mindset
the mission can be I'm in a season of
figuring out my life cool at least
you're clear that you're in a season of
recovery reflection of trying stuff
awesome but when you're just like I have
no clue what I want to do you were in a
power of this mindset number two when
we're controlled by fear again that
doesn't mean that there's not going to
be fear that comes up but when it
controls us we are powerless to it
so that's why we have a lot of exercises
about overcoming fear when we're
crippled by self-doubt again for me I
was crippled by it for a long time the
fear of judgment and not feeling enough
not feeling lovable not feeling enough
and it was really me learning to feel
enough to myself
I seeked it from outside validation but
still didn't believe it internally so I
was learning how about how to have a new
relationship with self and stop
abandoning myself in this process to
overcome self-doubt the fourth one I
think a lot of people don't talk about
when it comes to mindset is concealing
past pains
this is something that I think a lot of
men struggle with the idea of actually
sharing their past pain
and
I am just a big believer based on all
the science and all the research and all
the therapists and neuroscientists I've
interviewed and talked about in the book
that when we conceal past pains
it hurts us more it's more of a poison
inside of us and it affects us and our
abilities to feel peace and abundance
and Harmony better when we have
something in us that we're afraid to
share for 25 years I held inside of me
that I'd been sexually abused until 10
years ago I opened up about it uh
privately with people and eventually
started talking about it publicly
because I wanted to give men more of a
permission to open up about all their
shames or pains not in a public setting
but being able to talk to a good friend
therapist priest or whatever it is for
you when we conceal it means we're
afraid and we have shame around
something that has happened or that we
did
and I just think that keeps us powerless
um
the fifth thing is being defined by the
opinions of others
it doesn't mean don't get feedback and
support from others but being defined by
them as our identity is what holds us
back and makes us powerless that's an
interesting balance then you know the
same as the is it belief or is it action
yes is it fear of insufficiency or is it
desired for more is it feedback from the
world around us or is it completely
reliant on what they think about us this
is the virtuous mean as Aristotle called
it right you know the middling section
where it's not so much that it's toxic
but not so little that it's ineffective
and that appropriate dose for certain
things like to get feedback from the
people around you or the World At Large
right
the actual band that you're playing with
isn't all that wide I know it's really
difficult to manage to find it right did
you um
did you have any really good coaches
growing up in sports and Cricket or
anything else you played in so
no not really not in terms of mindset
what can I say man I mean the guys they
were fantastic at what they taught but I
never once learned the value of practice
I never learned the line between putting
in work now that would facilitate a
performance in the future and I remember
being so before I did the podcast I I
was always a little bit resentful of the
fact that I I had this sort of Drive I
wanted to do things I felt like Yeah I
wanted to have a thing that I could
commit myself to
and I didn't have a thing I could commit
myself to I I'd run this business one of
those things but you didn't have it I
didn't have a I didn't have a vector
through which I could put this passion
right I'm good at being obsessive I'm
very good at being obsessive
and I remember being almost resentful
about the fact that I didn't learn the
line between practice and performance I
didn't understand the relationship
between putting in reps and how that's
going to facilitate you in the future
and now I felt like I was in my late 20s
and what what [__] hobby am I going
to find now that's going to allow me
that's going to be the you know the the
vector through which I can do this oh
[__] knows and then the podcast came
along and Peterson one of his rules is
commit yourself to one thing to try as
hard as you can and see what happens
yeah and maybe it doesn't work out the
way you want it maybe it works out
better yes sometimes or maybe you
realize that's not what you want to do
but at least you can cross over that's
the Robert Greene thing exactly but it's
also the Stephen pressfield turning pro
thing yeah but the war of art thing
which is that when you do decide to
commit yourself to one thing you learn
an awful lot just about the process in
general and
um you know that again I I feel for
people that have the desire to be great
at something to try hard at something
they've got the conscientiousness the
obsessiveness the work rate they've got
those things but they haven't found the
right Avenue they haven't found the
thing the mechanism yes and that's where
that that's that makes me feel really
sad for those people because you think
God you dude you've got all the raw
materials the core potential the talent
yeah so in that situation that's where
that you mentioned earlier on the
explore exploit framework yeah dude just
try someone message me again I get quite
a lot now
uh pieces of advice requests and stuff
online and this one guy sent a really
well-meaning message and I said I'm in
my 30s I haven't found the thing that I
want to do the friends around me don't
seem like they've got my best interests
at heart I drink more than I want to
because I don't have anything else to do
blah blah blah I was like dude commit to
one thing a month for the next year like
the first month you're gonna try improv
then it's going to be interpretive dance
then it's going to be exactly like
painting then it's going to be blogging
then it's going to be whatever because
if you genuinely feel like you've got
that that fuel inside of you to be great
at something and you haven't found the
thing that fuel is going to either get
used to be to drive an engine or turn
toxic exactly because unfulfilled or
unrequited life desires are going to
murder you inside absolutely man yeah
and that's why I think we've got to
figure out what that meaningful mission
is and try a bunch of stuff until you
get clear and even once you're clear
that thing might change a year five ten
years later you know I loved baseball
until I didn't I played from five years
old till I was 17 and then one summer
after the season was done I was just
like
I don't think I want to do this anymore
it was part of my mission until I had
new interests until it wasn't I was like
actually I'm not getting fulfilled
enjoyment from this like I was and
that's okay that's a really interesting
point to bring up because I think a lot
of people presume that what they're
about to embark on now is going to be
there forever no it's a very juvenile
approach and I have this again this is
me speaking to myself not only now but
in the past
it's not the thing that you're pursuing
now can be periodized it can just be for
the next few years exactly and David
data talks about this in the way the
superior man at the very start he says
the thing which used to light you up now
no longer makes you feel alive and it's
like a crab outgrowing itself and all of
the things and the the routines and you
have to force yourself to go to the gym
to go to practice to see your friends to
go out and party whatever it might be
and that's
a signal that's you being poked and
someone's saying dude this this isn't
really aligned for you so much anymore
maybe you got to find something new but
the advantage of that is there is less
pressure on you to get the thing that
you choose it's not got to be the life
purpose for the rest of time it can just
be for the next three years what's the
season and that's why I love sports and
allergies I mean I'm an athlete but I
mean you look at
the guys who I mean JJ Watts an example
he just retired he was like an All-Star
NFL one of the top NFL players in the
last decade and he realized I'd
accomplished everything I wanted to like
this season has run its course and
that's why it's important to have an off
season to be able to reflect and say is
this something I want to do anymore let
me reflect on this and get clear on my
mission for the next season or I'm in a
new chapter I'm discovering something
new and I think the other the last part
of the power of this mindset is when you
drift towards complacency when we stay
in that place
we are just powerless to not having a
clear Mission and not wanting to grow
and improve and I'm not saying that we
should be working hard and pushing
ourselves to the Limit constantly every
day in extreme levels but if we stay
complacent I just know we won't also be
happy and be joyful in consistent
complacency
you know there might be a season of time
where that's fine and the greatness
mindset it's really it's what's
reflecting do I have any of these six
areas
on a continual basis and asking yourself
am I in any of these sticks at any
moment do I lack a meaningful Mission
controlled by fear all these things if
so again you're not bad and wrong
nothing about that it's just
are you using your talents to the best
your ability and if not now we're aware
of it and the greatest mindset is being
driven by a meaningful mission for me I
have one sentence that I'm driven by and
that's to serve an impact 100 million
lives weekly to help them improve the
quality of their life
that's my mission the mechanisms can
change it could be podcasting and
YouTube today it could be blogging
tomorrow I have no idea whatever that
I'm passionate about and have power and
talent in I'm going to lean into the
mechanisms with that mission
but I am clear and most people listening
or watching
they can't tell their friends in one
sentence what their mission is they can
say well I'm working this job or I'm in
this relationship or I've got these
goals but what is the mission of this
season of life
and I think when you get clear in one
sentence for yourself and you can speak
it
then you can act accordingly it's really
easy to say yes and no to things because
you know what's going to serve the
mission or what's not going to serve it
so it's just getting as clear as
possible and again you don't
it can be like I'm just trying to make a
couple Grand a month to get off my
sister's couch okay cool then you're
clear on this Mission until you
accomplish it there's a really great
Insight from Jeff Bezos when he was
still at Amazon both him and musk had a
single ordinating principle that they
wrapped everything around and for Bezos
it was does this improve the customer
experience yes one question does this
improve customer experience for musk it
was does this get us closer to Mars does
this get us close to Mars and when you
have a single orienting principle with
it and this is what I really like about
talking about seasons of life or periods
of life is that it allows you to
optimize very very narrow but very very
deep on one area so at some point I
can't wait to have a family and when I
do
for a big chunk of time my goal is going
to be be the best father that I can
that's right and that's it and that's
good with your season yes the season of
fatherhood yes right and that will be
all that I'm bothered about all that I
want to do everything else facilitates
me being the best father that I can be
that's exciting but it's not right now
it's not right now it's not your season
right now yes and I like that it takes
the pressure off I think having to get
this grand plan right
and that's why again I just think
everything is seasons of life and
figuring out what season you're in and
being okay with this season and working
on your mission for this season so when
you're driven by a meaningful Mission
you're clear on that
it just gives you it doesn't mean
there's not going to be challenges and
adversity and things you got to work
hard to do every day you're going to
probably work harder but at least you
know where you're going
second one is again turning the fears
into confidence that's why we talk about
figuring out all these different tools
and modalities for overcoming fear and
we've got all the different research and
Neuroscience that talks about that
overcome self-doubt I think that's when
you're stepping into greatness the
mindset of overcoming it and it may be a
constant journey of overcoming
self-doubt and every season brings new
doubts
you know how to live your life now but
until you're a father you're not going
to know what to do and there might be
six months to a year to four years we're
like I'm kind of doubting myself so
you're gonna have to go all in on it and
overcome it and it's going to be a new
season for you to overcome new doubts
uh heals past pains again I think if we
conceal these things it's just going to
make us suffer creating a healthy
identity for me this is part of the uh
the mindset in motion the thing you were
talking about when our thoughts our
emotions and our behaviors the
intersection intersection of them is
really creating a new mindset of
identity around our beliefs from our
thoughts our behaviors and our actions
but a lot of us again going back to that
unhealthy identity if we recorded the
thoughts in our mind they would probably
send us to a mental hospital if they
said it out loud what was that movie was
it Netflix that did it about two years
ago and everybody walked around with
this sort of Aura Halo and it was
colored and it would speak out the
thoughts that they had yeah what was
that called people are screaming into
their iPods anyway that that movie and I
thought everyone's considered that right
everyone's considered what is the world
like what would the world be like if our
inner thoughts were broadcast out to
everybody else crazy yeah it would be it
would be wild and if you wouldn't speak
to a friend the way that you talk to
yourself
yeah why do you talk to yourself that
way yeah and I get it this is the way
we've been conditioned and trained but
it doesn't serve us it's not effective
it only makes us feel worse about who we
are feeling worse about who we are only
as good if we recognize oh I made a
mistake
that was my bad let me take
responsibility and ownership I said this
thing that wasn't okay let me ask myself
why I said this thing to make sure I
don't do it in the future that's the
only time it's really good to kind of I
guess quote unquote and beat yourself up
is when you're like
actually hurt someone I did something
bad that was wrong that was immoral that
was against the law
let me take a look at myself and realize
okay let me take full ownership
actually beating yourself up isn't good
still but feeling that
I guess healthy shame is good because
you don't want to do that bad thing
again but then holding on to it for
years and Decades of your life does not
serve you or your mission or the people
around you
so learn to integrate the lesson heal
and move on
um
but creating that healthy identity I
think is something and again I know like
I've heard I think Goggins talked about
this on your show where he was like
listen you can't just like scream
affirmations at yourself in the mirror
all the time
and I don't think it's about
affirmations I think it's about an
internal dialogue backed by action and
belief within that action putting in the
Reps and saying oh man you know I'm
proud I did that 30 minutes today of
that work that I said I was gonna do so
now I can believe and accept myself more
for who I am I think that's what it is
taking action with a game plan that's
part of the greatness mindset when we
when we don't take action with a clear
game plan whether the game plan works or
not but being clear on it consistently
then we're living in a powerless mindset
state of being and we just want to try
to move towards the greatest mindset
more frequently as possible but the
mindset in motion is really the
intersection of the thoughts behaviors
and emotions
and it's the sweet spot where how you
think how you feel and how you act all
come together
and I think that's
again if we have poor
behaviors if we have poor thoughts we're
probably going to not feel good about
ourselves
so how do we shift our thoughts so we
can feel better and how do we shift our
behaviors our actions so we can feel
better as well I think a lot of this
comes back to the emotions of the heart
when we think a certain way
it makes us feel a certain way when we
act a certain way it makes us think and
feel a certain way so it's the
intersection of all these things making
sure our thoughts
our behaviors
and our emotions are in congruence with
our highest level of thinking our
highest level of love and harmony
and if one of them is off it will affect
the other two and it'll make us feel
like we're trying to catch up or make
sure make us feel like we got a chip on
our shoulder and this is not a make
wrong or good or bad it is what is most
effective for you as a human being to
actualize your potential to feel the
most love and harmony in your in your
heart
and do some good in the in the world
with the people around you that's what
I'm talking about
what would your stomach is is confirming
it too it's speaking well you can tell
I'm fasted today all right me too yeah
um what would you say to someone that's
listening and goes this is great I like
the idea of a greatness mindset I'm
aware that I've got limiting beliefs I'm
aware that I've got fears what are some
actionable first steps that you would
give to a friend that came to you and
said book's great mate um what do I do I
would do an assessment first and I'll do
this assessment with you on a scale of
one to ten let's call it the
self-love inner peace scale hypothetical
scale feeling inner peace and feeling a
sense of love for yourself not a
narcissistic love but an actual
authentic love for yourself one being
you hate yourself and have zero peace in
your life
internally 10 being you have your bliss
100 of the time and you love and accept
who you are at all times where are you
currently on a you know General scale of
one to ten probably a strong seven or a
soft eight somewhere in between a seven
that's awesome so for you it's just
asking yourself do you want to go a
little bit further are you trying to go
you know further towards that 10 or do
you like where you're at and the goal is
everyone to ask yourself kind of where
are you on that scale and I used to why
is that the first place that you go to I
think it's first just taking an
assessment and the book is really about
multiple assessments of asking yourself
where are you and are you happy where
you're at and if you want to create
something new then here are the examples
the science the research the experts
it's not about me it's about all the
experts I've brought in to solve the
problems that I had 10 years ago five
years ago two years ago this is the book
I wish I had when I was 16 and
struggling trying to find a girlfriend
and deal with the emotions of heartbreak
this is the book I wish I had at 23 when
I was broken wrist and on my sister's
couch trying to figure out my mission
next it's a book I wish I had 10 years
ago before I started this whole journey
because that's what I was looking for
these solutions from all these experts
with backed science and research not
just I tried this thing and here it
worked for me but what works against
every discipline in every industry with
different individuals from Neuroscience
therapy medical doctors world-class
athletes and billionaires what works for
them to create peace Harmony and
ultimate success
along with impact with others that is
the intersection of greatness this is
what Kobe talked about when I had them
on it was not about him winning it's
about him inspiring the people around
him to win as well it's about them
feeling loved that's what he talked
about in the interview it wasn't about
being the best it's about how can I
inspire people to be their best to then
Inspire others to be their best and feel
a sense of love and community in the
process and I think if that's something
you feel like you're missing or you want
more of then this is a good place to
start
Louis how's ladies and gentlemen where
should people go if I want to keep up to
date with the stuff that you do
appreciate you brother
um the greatest mindset is the book you
can check it out anywhere the school of
greatness podcast
or at Lewis house anywhere on social
media I appreciate you man thank you for
following up thanks brother appreciate
you
well thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace
foreign
[Music]